hepiniz hoş geldiniz adım
Ben de Germiyan köyünden geliyorum Çeşme
İzmir İnşallah uçan arabalar Bizim
izmir'imize de gelir Eray
Bey şey Jetgiller hatırladım sizin bu
projeyle benim değişim de işte köyüme
yaptığım bir çizimlerle
başladı Yıl 2014 biz Hazırlanıyoruz şey
yapmak için köyümüzü tanıtmak için ne
yaparız yaparız ne yaparız köyde kafeler
yapalım dedik Şimdi bizim köyün içinden
yol geçiyor ama ben bunu artık düzelttim
Bütün her e şehirde köyde kasabada
Yollar geçiyor da Giden gittiği yer
önemli şimdi bizim köyün içinden yol
geçiyor Ama biz hiçbir faydalanıyoruz
Trafik çok gürültü çok ne yaparız ne
yaparız köye dedik kafeler yapalım da
insanları köye sokalım
E onun için ne yapalım
Eee ya biz Hoca Nasrettin Türklerin
ginde var ya önce tabel yazdık astık
bizim artık köyümüzün kafeleri var Biz
kafelerle çıktık bu yola kafeler
yapacağız diye Ondan sonra dedim ki Ben
arkadaşlara ham bir tarzımız olsun dedik
ahşap sandalyeler Masalar olsun Ondan
sonra
eee böyle devam edeceğiz önce tabelaları
yazdık astık Hoca Nasrettin Hani evinin
kapısı yok da ama duvarı yok kapısı ve
kilidi var aynı Bizimkisi de bizim
hiçbir şeyimiz yok ama artık tabelaları
yazdık asık ya bizim artık kafeler imiz
var ondan sonra
eee Ben sandalye boyayacağım boyayacağım
diye çıktım sandalyeler geldi başladım
boyamaya İlk birkaç tane sandalye
boyadım bana dediler ki aynı at arabası
gibi oldu bunu mu yapacaktı bayağı bir
üzüldüm sıkıldım Moralim bozuldu modum
düştü ama tabii Ben şimdi kendim hep
köyün delisi diyorum biraz deli olmak
güzel bir şey Siz bunları beğenmediniz
dedim ama düşünün Hindistan'ı pakistan'a
insanlar İşte bu e resimli kamyonları
otobüsleri görmeye gidiyor bu bir sektör
artık dedim siz onlar beğenmedin mi bana
şöyle bir çaktı O zaman ben dedim
duvarlara geçiyorum Köyü boyunca sizce
ne demişlerdir Burası benim e köyüm
olduğu halde Eee İzmir'in bir Köyü
olduğu halde işte bayağı bilinen tanınan
bir yer olduğu halde ama eğitim yüksek
seviyesi yüksek olduğu halde ne
dedikleri bellidir 3 aşağı be y tahmin
ediyorsunuzdur ne işin var Sen deli
misin Vallahi dedim Ben ts'li Deliyim
ben bu işi yapacağım göreceksiniz köy
tanınacak Tabii ilk önce insanlar bazı
şeyleri Hayal
edemiyor Her neyse bir sürü deli meli
lafı arasında Ben başladım köyün
duvarlarını
boyamaya birkaç bir şeyler
oldu işte sen kendin bunları adadın da
ne yapıyorsun da Köyü bulamaca çevirdin
de hiçbir işin mi yok da falan derken
ben Köyü başladım boyama yıl
2016 şeye Hazırlanıyoruz bizim
Festivalimiz var gelmeyen festivale ona
Hazırlanıyoruz ne yapacağız Ne yapacağız
derken bana D dokunuyorsun Ben şu arkada
gördü bay bayan kuşu boyuyorum ondan
sonra bir tane toplantıya Beni de
çağırdılar dedim bana dokunmuyoruz Ben
şu bay bayan kuşu tamamlayacağım Ondan
sonra dedim Gelip insanlar önünde resim
çekilecek Her neyse onu çizerken resmimi
çekiyorlar bir tanesi diyor ki Nuran
abla resmini çekebilir miyim çek dedim
bir tanesi dedi ki Ben salak mıyım dedi
Ben de çekeceğim İyi o da çekti çek
dedim o çektiği resmi kız kendi
sayfasında yayınlıyor aslal bayrak diye
birisi onun resmini 1000 kişi beğeniyor
sonra o resmi bir 5000 kişi beğeniyor o
resmi cez bir sayfasında yayınlıyor bir
gecede 5.000 kişi şey 89 86.000 kişi
tıklıyor günün fenomeni Bütün Türkiye'de
Ben 86.000 kişi tıklayınca bu sefer şey
başlıyor e halamın torunları geldi bana
diyor ki Nuran abla Nuran abla efendim
seni cezm kalorifer yayınlamış Hani Zeki
Alasya Metin Akpınar filmi var ya ben de
hiç bilgisayar yok bilgisayardan hiç
anlamam İnternetten hiç anlamam bana
gösteriyorlar 32.000 34.000 36 benim
takıldığım tek şey şu Yahu diyorum
kalorifer soyat mı olurmuş Ondan sonra
Her neyse bizim kalorifer soy atlı
adamın sayesinde Biz y Ben diyorum ki
sosyal medyanın azizliğine uğradık ama
iyi anlamda uğradık O sayede Ne oldu
gecede 86.000 kişi tıklayınca bu sefer
ulusal basın Haydi bakalım hücum ilk
Haber Türk arıyor Nuran Hanım siz
misiniz benim işte çekime geleceğiz
gelebiliriz gel arkasından ihlasa bir
Ajansı aradı Nuran Hanım siz misiniz
Evet benim çekime geleceğiz gelebilir mi
ona da gel arkasından Doğan Haber Ajansı
hiç haber vermeden biri kamera atıyor
biri mikrofonu Siz nereden çıktınız Biz
de geldik hadi siz de
gelin ben onlara şey bir gün de röportaj
verdim Ekim ayının başından ortasına
kadar 2016 yılında bütün ülkede Fenomen
çobanlıktan ressamlığa işte çiftçilikten
ressamlığa derken o gün bugündür bu
işleri yapıyoruz düşünün Ben teden
arıyorlar e birkaç gün geçti
2016'da Nuran Hanım seni tedeke
çağırıyoruz yavrum dedi bak Senin
konuşman bana nasıl geliyor biliyor
musun Almanca Fransızca İngilizce gibi
bile değil uzaydan birisi konuşuyor Ben
dedim tdx adını duymadım Ne konuşacağım
da bilmem ne yapacağım Sen bana şunu ded
Türkçe bir açılımını yap ya abla
Geleceksin dedi Nur Hanım dedi Pardon
geleceksin ne yaptığını anlatacaksın
Dedim ha dedim Sorun değil Ben konuşmaya
başladımı susturmaya para isterim şimdi
bak buraya da ben hiç hazırlanmadan
geldim vallahi size doğ Aşlama
konuşuyorum Ondan sonra o gün bugündür
konuşuyoruz şimdi benim bu işte diyorum
ya köyün delisi olmak güzel bir şey deli
olduğum için artık fazla da bulaşmıyor
ne oldu Çok güzel bir şey oldu benim
köyüm tur kapsamına girdi şu an
alaçatıya Çeşme'ye git gitmek için gelen
insanlar zaman ayırıyor artık benim
köyüme giriyor 15 dakika 20 dakika bazen
yarım saat ne oldu ama bu bu nedir Bence
Sanatın Gücü Sanat evrensel bir dil Bana
diyorlar ki neden hep çiçek neden dedim
hep çiçek Çünkü çiçek evrensel bir dil
kadınlarımız var Burada ev hanımlarımız
işte annelerimiz
öğretmenlerimiz öğrencilerimiz de ne
yapar evini temizlediği zaman veya bir
şey güzel yaptığı zaman ne der o mis
gibi oldu çiçek gibi oldu demez mi çiçek
evrensel bir deil ve çiçek benim için
hayatta en güzel şeylerden bir tanesi
Eee ben herkese de diyorum aile çok
önemli bir olay ailenin güzel olması çok
önemli bir olay Şimdi çiçek
getirdi benim babam Allah rahmet eylesin
anneme verirken dedi ki Hanım karısın
seven adam karısına çiçek verir Buyur
Hanım Biz böyle bir ailede büyüdüğümüz
için bizim için çiçek çok önemli ve
çiçeğin
Eee birleştirici Onur edici olduğuna da
inanıyorum şimdi bu sayede dedim ya Turk
kapsamına girdi Şimdi bana genç genç
çocuklar geliyorlar ğ öğrencileri alıp
Getiriyorlar benimle tanıştırmaya işte
dediniz ya biraz önce değişimin bir
parçası olmak işte biz de onlara örnek
olarak gösteriyorlar çocuklar geliyor
çocuklara diyorum ki bakın çocuklar yani
hocalar da var burada ama kızmayın biraz
ben abi yan konuşmayı da seviyorum
küfürlü değil ama çocuklara diyorum ki
bakın çocuklar gittiğiniz yerde ağzınızı
ayra ayra gezmeyin Etrafınıza güzel
bakın
[Müzik]
etrafınızdaki içmesi onlar size diyor
mutlaka orası hakkında bilgi verecektir
Eee biraz diyorum ya hani abih hane
konuşuyorum ama çocuklar çok böyle almak
zamanında Hayat zaten ben bunu kaç
gündür de söylüyorum Hayat giriş gelişme
sonuç değil mi onlar tam giriş zamanında
şimdi bak bu etkinliği hazırlayan
çocuklara da bakayım o kadar güzel
heyecanları var O kadar güzel motive
olmuşlar ki böyle Pırpır ediyorlar
onlara örnek olmamız lazım benim
yaptığım şey Belki çok çok önemli bir
şey değil ama ne oldu işte diyorum ya bu
sayede benim meksika'dan insanlar
geliyor ziyarete Amerika'dan Almanya'dan
yurt içinden bazen diyor ki adam ay Ben
Ankara'dan geldim diyor vallahi millet
Almanya'dan geliyor diyor sen Ankara'dan
gelmek çok bir iş değil
Eee değişim için ilk önce biz kendimiz
Belki de
değişeceği yapabilmek insanlara ilham
olabilmek insanlara bir şey verebilmek
için insanlar önce vermeyi bilecek Çünkü
E benim çocukluk
hayalimdi çocukken Hani herkesin vardır
bir hayalleri Ben mutlaka üniversite
okuyacağım mutlaka ben Köyü tanıtacağım
diye çıktım Allah'a çok şükür onlar da
kısmet oldu
Eee yani Çocuklara hep anlattığım şu Ne
olursunuz çocuklar diyorum hayalleriniz
olsun ve o hayallerin peşinden gitmeye
çalışın Yoksa yani hani hayalleri
olmayan insanların Eee gelecekte de söz
sahibi olmaları çok da yani olacak bir
şey değil bence hayalleri olmalı o
Hayaller üstünde çalışın çalışmadan da
hiçbir şey yok çalışacaksın çalışacaksın
çalışacaksın yani bana diyorlar ki
nereden aklına geldi Vallah de aklıma
gelmedi O biraz Tesadüf oldu ama bana
diyorlar eğitim mi aldım Yok ben
Halıcılık Tan mezunum ama çiziyordum gün
bir gün E şey evdeyim Köydeyim masanın
başına taş çiziyorum bir kadın geldi ay
bunları yapanı tanıyor musunuz dedi
Vallah dedim ben oluyorum ay şöyle bir
baktı kadın sen misin he benim dedim Ne
var Beğenemedin mi yok beğenemedim dedi
Ben zannettim ki dedi İstanbul'dan
Birileri geldi çizdi Tabii dedim
haklısın bir tek İstanbul'daki
insanların elini fırça ve kalem tutuyor
Vallah dedim ben de becerebildim bak bu
işleri ondan sonra sen dedim şimdi sana
göre ne ressam şimdi insanlarda hala
öyle kalıplar var ki şey diyor yani
onlar çizmiş diye düşünü Madem burada
olduğunu bilmediğin bir şeyse niye
köydeki birisine soruyorsun değil mi
Bunu ondan sonra Vallah dedim Bak şimdi
Senin kafandaki ressam şu saçının yarısı
mor turuncu pembe olacak işte eteğinin
biri yerde biri gökte olacak işte ya
kulunda ya boynunda dedim flar olacak
Ondan sonra Entel Dantel olacak dedim
Oras Tamam ama vah deim ben daha entel
dantelim hem şalvarım var dedim hem
Başörtüm var ya böyle ilginç şeyler
oluyor sonra üniversitelerden geliyorlar
Bazen bilmem ne üniversitesinden hepsi
kelli Adam akademisyenler şöyle bir
yayılıyor e otur bakalım Nuran Hanım
Bunu nasıl yaptın Bir başladın anlat
bakalım
anlatayım ya çok ilginç insanlar
görüyorsun şöyle bir yayılıyor Ondan
sonra oturuyoruz konuşuyoruz konuşuyoruz
başlıyorlar düzelmeye başlıyor en son
şöyle en Nuran Hanım ah diyorum şimdi
kıvama geldiniz hala insanlar Bugünde
bile düşünün atomu parçalamaktan daha
zormuş ön yargıları parçalamak ya hala
daha hani İşte kıyafetinden dolayı seni
ya baştan bir kere damgalı aptalsın gibi
bir şey bilmiyorsun gibi ama çok güzel
diyorum ya çok güzel şeyler yaşıyoruz
böyle düşünün benim makamına
çıkamayacağım
insanlar benim ile tanışmak için geliyor
düşünün ta daha bu işte sosyal medyanın
azizliğine uğramadan bile düşün İmren
Aykut Benim resimlerimi görmüş nereden
gördüyse geldi Benimle tanışmaya
Düşünsene köyde yaptın küçücük bir
hareket sonucu bir bakanlık yapmış
birisinin seni ziyarete gelmesi veya
işte bazen geliyor soruyorum ben Biraz
meraklıyım da çok da
konuşurum Nereden geldiniz diyorum Adam
diyor ki ben oxford'da doçenti diyor Bak
çocuğum dedim nasıl verdiler der sana
orayı Vallahi abla diyor 3 gün masadan
kalkmadan ders çalıştım onun için
diyorum ya çalışacaksın yani şey hedefin
olacak hedefin çalışacaksın bir şeyler
yapacaksın bir şeyler Öğreteceksin işte
buralara gelmek için de hani böyle
geçenlerde bir şeye çağırdılar Biraz
benim diyorum ya dilimin ayarı yok
çocuklar falan çok ilgi çekiyor
ilgilerini çekiyor görsel şey hafıza
insanların çok kuvvetli Ya şey
çağırdılar Ne
o hayal gücü derneğine çağırdılar
oralara gittim
Eee yani Düşünsene 8 12 18 yaş
arasındaki insanların çocukların
dikkatini çekmek Çünkü benim yaşım artık
belli bir yaşın üstündeyim ben hani
giriş gelişme dedim ya biz sonuca doğru
gidenlerdeniz
Eee bu insanlara ilham olmak buralarda
gelip konuşmak bir tanesinin bile
hayatına dokunabilsem Bu o kadar
kıymetli ki
Eee çocuklarınızı Sakın sen yapamazsın
bizim ailelerimizin en büyük
hatalarından biri Sen çocuğumu
yapamazsın Niye yapamazsın Bir kere
yapamazsa iki kere yapamazsa üncü de
yapacak zaten hani şey önlerine
hayallerine e
heveslerine ilgilerine böyle şey ket
vurmayın Onları böyle engellemeyin daha
böyle ellerinden tutup gitmek
istedikleri yerlere getirmeye çalışın
biraz önce Rabia'nın dediği gibi işte
toplumsal baskı direkt aile baskısı
olmasa bile toplumsal baskı zaten çok
fazla
Eee Bilmiyorum ya Hani çocuklara lütfen
Öğretmenler olarak veliler olarak
aileler olarak toplum olarak saygı
duyalım Çünkü bizim geleceğimiz onlar ve
şu an benim en çok üzüldüğüm şeylerden
bir tanesi ay okuyacağım de mutlaka yurt
dışına gideceğim ya yurt dışına
gideceksiniz de size böyle kırmızı
halılar falan sermi neden Türkiye'deki
en akıllı kişileri alıp götürüyorlar Biz
kültürümüzden toplumumuzun
bilgilerinden çok çok uzaklaştık
kendimize saygı duym Eee toplumumuza
saygı duymayı geçmişimize saygı duymayı
öğreneceğiz bana göre en önemli en
öncelikli gündemimiz olması gereken bu
dünyaya Medeni eti diyorum Biz Türkler
öğrettik şimdi böyle Hiçbir şey bilmişiz
gibi davranılıyor ben bu konuda çok
üzülüyorum dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ediyorum ayağınıza
sağlık